[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une droite la journée tech'innove qui
s'est déroulée aujourd'hui quinzième
édition
vous savez que celle l'événement
référence de l'innovation on va procéder
dans quelques instants à la remise des
prix la cérémonie de remise des prix
mais avec didier détenus bonjour vous
êtes un jour le président de l'assemblée
de commerce et d'industrie de l'essonne
et qui est le créateur qui est le
créateur de cet événement et puis avec
laurent le jambon jour vous êtes
résident de tech'innove vous êtes vous
est aussi directeur régional
ile-de-france d'airbus développement
virus développe non mais avec vous en
tant que président voilà on va essayer
de savoir c'est vrai que c'était une
journée un peu particulière avec des
concessions sanitaire qu'on connaît
comment s'est déroulée cette journée est
ce qu'elle a répondu à vos attentes
oui alors j'ai la lourde tâche de donner
les chiffres de cette journée qui est
une journée particulière parce que c'est
la première fois qu'on organisait le
selon tech'innove sous forme digitale et
c'est la crise de coliques qui nous y a
contraint et l'actualité d'hier nous a
montré que nous avions eu raison nous
avons eu mille plus de 1000 participants
à cette journée ce qui est ce qui est
une grande réussite puisque c'était une
première et surtout les chiffres du
digital donne le tournis on m'a 585
entités qui ont fait des demandes de
rendez-vous qui présentaient leur fiche
au préalablement à cette journée et qui
ont généré plus de quarante trois mille
visites sur sur ces facilités dans cet
énorme et la traduction en nombre de
rendez vous sur la journée est aussi
faramineuses puisque 6674 rendez vous se
sont tenues chacun de ces participants a
eu en moyenne une douzaine de rendez
vous et surtout ce qui est important est
inégalée c'est le nombre de rendez-vous
qui ont obtenu les start up c'est leur
journée 15 rendez-vous en moyenne par
start up dans la journée une journée
complète et pour les donneurs d'ordre
ils sont les grandes entreprises que ces
startups bien de rencontrer c'est une
dizaine de rendez-vous en moyenne et
pour les partenaires de ce salon ses
treize rendez vous en moyenne alors
c'est la journée de l'innovation nous
avons eu des
conférence également ces conférences ont
réuni chacune entre 50 et 90
participants ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu
faire dans une salle est donc grand de
grands succès avec des conférences qui
vont de la décarbonation de l'industrie
avec le cea jusqu'à au new space avec
cariste a donc des beaucoup de matières
scientifiques également puisque nous
sommes dans cette journée de
l'innovation est très bien suivie dans
très bien suivi noter qu'un challenge
dont je vais pas dévoiler les lauréats
non je laisserai les pôles de
compétitivité le faire tout à l'heure
puisque c'est le sait les organiser ça
avec 26 tap-tap particulièrement
intéressante et également des
entreprises qui viennent des territoires
dont 34 ont été mises à l'honneur par
leur propre territoire
voilà donc des chiffres qui donne un peu
le tournis et qui ont montré que l'on
pouvait innover dans cette nouvelle
formule
vers 10h10 d'innover et et c'est bien
une facile puisque la moindre des choses
presque mais cela dit il ya peut-être
une leçon à retenir c'est à dire que aux
fossettes cette façon de procéder
elle pourra peut-être perdurer dans
l'est dans les années qui viennent je
vous parle a dévoilé mais déjà elle va
même perdurer sans aller jusque déjà il
ya rien de mois d'avril or dans tout le
mois d'avril puisque tech'innove n'est
pas terminée
43 mille demandes de visites sur les
sites ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas pu avoir tous leurs rendez
vous mais je les rassure ils ont un mois
pour pouvoir planifier de nouveaux
rendez vous avec les gens qui n'ont pas
pu rencontrer aujourd'hui dotées de ces
vais être encore plus de rendez vous
pour les années puis zz pour les années
suivantes peut-être qu'on reviendra un
format présentiel parce que j'ai à
nouveau les rencontres humaines mais
peut-être aussi avec un formule mixte on
peut on peut tout à fait imaginer un
format hybride d'idées lui donc je
disais vous êtes
cci de l'essonne est à l'origine de
tech'innove on peut peut-être rappeler
un peu l'histoire ça fait 15 ans est la
quinzième édition 2007 la première tout
à fait tout à fait 2007 la première donc
partant d'un constat de mettre en
relation des start up avec des
investisseurs des laboratoires de
recherche
alors la logique était effectivement de
faire du du speed meeting mémé du speed
meeting qualifier c'est à dire qu'il
fallait que la personne qui demande un
rendez-vous la personne qui accepte et
le rendez vous soit tout à fait d'accord
pour que l'événement l'événement soit
soit intéressant sur allart en plus je
vois jean claude charvin d'écran etc
c'était le premier président et jean
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'était
l'ancien président qui qui a fait
beaucoup et qui a beaucoup oeuvré pour
que cet événement soit une réussite
alors nous l'avions organisé à orly
depuis 2007 jusqu'à 2018 mais bon
c'était quand même un petit peu trop
trop juste on avait quand même deux
étages 2 2 les regards ouest
non je suis autant pour moi mais bon ça
commence à être vraiment restreint et
puis l'événement comme m'étais vraiment
un événement de portée régionale voire
même voire même national donc on a
décidé de venir sur paris dans un
premier temps à l'espace champerret en
2019 qui était déjà une première
réussite et plus nés dernière la défense
une réussite fantastique à la défense
alors là c'était quelque chose de sur
5000 mètres carrés vraiment une des
possibilités de important pour une fois
là cette fois ci les territoires été mis
aussi en exergue comme ils ont été mis
aujourd'hui et donc c'est devenu leur
wendel je dirais l'événement
incontournable de l'innovation
maintenance et je pense que c'est c'est
une map market place qui est
incontournable maintenant sur sur
l'innovation je pense que même les
grands comptes maintenant comprennent le
rang intérêt de venir chanter qui
n'avait de trouver de trouver ces
startups
il est innovante et performante les
entreprises qui était qu'ils étaient des
entreprises à l'origine plutôt de la
région maintenant et ça ça vient de
toutes deux le territoire entre est un
outil je crois même qu'on avait une
délégation japonaise d'année dernière
c'est sain
les deux ans il ya deux ans il ya deux
ans il ya deux ans il ya une délégation
japonaise
vous voyez que on est on est en dehors
de nos frontières
largement et le plateau de saclay et ans
d'innovation par excellence il est
important que ces événements là un lieu
sûr je suis au territoire
alors on s'est posé la question savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait cette année comment
voit il passe est ce qu'on continue est
ce qu ont connue parce que vous avez
douté à un moment vous êtes diplômé e d
c'était à risque comme des riches il ya
quand même il ya quand même le côté le
côté financier de 2 de l'opération et
puis vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que que
les finances des chambres ont été
malmenés jusqu'à maintenant donc
important de savoir comment comment on
allait se vouvoyer puis finalement lady
bon on se lance on le fait en fait
totalement dématérialisé et puis ça nous
servira de voir si on s'est trompé on
s'est trompé les chiffres que vient de
notre sens que vous êtes pas trompés
c'est vrai qu'on a pris on appris on a
pris la bonne option et je rejoins tout
à fait je pense que l'année prochaine
parce que côté physique important je
pense que tu as envie on vit un moment
compliqué tout ça cause avec toutes ces
visions tu sais on a envie de mâcon bid
et du contact humain je pense qu'il va
falloir trouver le bon mix ça va ça va
se trouver cela se trouve facilement
je le pense donc demain tech'innove
conservera ses sept
cette dimension online si l'on peut dire
mais le côté physique et dynamique du
business doit aussi se faire sur un côté
présentiel bien sûr alors on est en
ligne avec didier kling bonjour bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président des
chambres de commerce et d'industrie
d'île de france
d'abord vous devez être ravi de la
réussite je suppose de tech'innove mais
je pense que vous l'y ai aussi parlé que
dans cette période très compliquée
évidemment pour l'économie très
compliqué pour les entreprises de
l'accompagnement que font les chambres
de commerce et d'industrie en
particulier à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'ile-de-france pour les
pour les entreprises oui bien sûr mais
avant toute chose je voudrais remercier
et féliciter la chambre de commerce de
l'essonne et son président qui vient de
s'exprimer puis félicité aussi laurent
le gentil président de take it off
excellente initiative y en a ici un bon
exemple d'une start up qui a bien réussi
elle a démarré c'est vrai à orly s'est
agrandie nier et didier vient de dire
les lieux dans lesquels elle s'est
progressivement transférés je te rassure
didier on a aussi pour toi disposition
tu le sais bien dans la chanteuse région
le bourget villepinte où la porte de
verre de l'évolution du nombre de
participants donc on pourra accompagner
la poursuite du développement de
tech'innove et ça montre que lorsqu'il
ya une bonne idée au départ et c'est une
bonne idée
et lorsqu'une bonne réalisation d'une
bonne exécution oui à une innovation
telle que celle là peut trouver
normalement sont son chemin et son
d'épanouissement elle deuxième chose que
je voudrais dire c'est que bien sûr
aujourd'hui on voit bien que nous sommes
dans une situation un peu compliquée
c'était difficile d'organiser une
manifestation comme l'année dernière et
il a fallu de la flexibilité et le
courage de de didier de laurent pour
arrêter sous cette forme digitale
je prendrai un exemple volontiers pour
savoir comment les choses peuvent
évoluer l'année prochaine on savait tous
qu'il ya une grande manifestation à
laquelle vous n'êtes pas encore tout à
fait parvenus mais vous allez bientôt
les dépasser je pensais le cs de las
vegas confort que le positionnement sur
légèrement différent cette année le
seven bells riga s'est tenue sous une
forme digitale
et il ya eu un sondage qui était fait
ensuite pour savoir ce qu'en pense et
les participants qui ne sont pas
franchement hostile à la digitalisation
par nature et par vocation
85 % d'entre eux ont dit c'est très bien
à la forme digitale
mais franchement on envie de retourner à
las vegas donc on a besoin de contacts
physiques ce qui veut bien dire qu'il
faut sans doute imaginé et dieu sait si
lyon on le fait dans nos autres
activités une formule hybride à la fois
la digitalisation même temps le contact
physique parce que nous avons besoin de
nous retrouver de bavarder dans des
conditions peut être différente qu'un
écran qui constitue un peu un barrage
entre les contacts humains
après ça reste à savoir effectivement ce
que nous faisons en termes d'innovation
pour essayer d'accompagner les
entreprises vous savez dans le cadre du
plan de relance il ya notamment un volet
accompagnement mystère d'économie
défiance a demandé aux chambres de
commerce de manifester leur activité
leur dynamisme dans ce domaine c'est ce
que nous faisons
on près d'un nombre significatif de
l'entreprise par exemple dans le seul
domaine industriel nous avons accompagné
plus de 3800 entreprises nous avons de
multiples actions mais didier déconner
il pourra en parler aussi ça va sa maman
que moi et nous savons très bien que la
relance passe aussi par l'innovation il
n'y aura pas de développement économique
si a pas d'innovation et c'est parce
qu'il ya des innovations que nous
pouvons assurer la croissance du
territoire dans l'intérêt même des
personnes physiques qui occupait ce
territoire avec un grand débat actuel
comme ceux qui se déroule sur la loi
climat
nous ne sommes pas favorable
décroissance qui est une théorie qui se
répend parfois nous croyons que la
croissance économique parfaitement sur
conjuguer avec le respect et la défense
de la planète et l'innovation va y
contribuer puissamment très bien merci
merci beaucoup didier kling la relance
passe par l'innovation
c'est la phrase que je retiendrai et qui
pourrait trop faut aussi des death le
gros des slogans de tech'innove merci
beaucoup
on va passer tout à l'heure à la remise
des prix
gendre mais on est très heureux
d'accueillir olivier diers bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le fondateur de la
société hyperion ses hommes
c'est ça qui est une société spécialisée
dans les systèmes de drones sécurisé qui
servent parfois des événements sportifs
qui servent aussi à la sécurité
enfin plusieurs applications possibles
c'est une toute jeune société un tout
jeune oui on est issu de deux
laboratoires de recherche de
l'université de lyon la boit elle vit
sur l'innovation de sport et de la boad
gl qui est le labo de géologie de lyon
et on a été créée en juillet 2010 9
juillet 2010 des valeurs est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter parce que c'est ça
qui est passionnant aujourd'hui en quoi
tu es kind of a pu vous aider une jeune
société créatrice et innovatrices comme
la vôtre
mais pour nous tech'innove a été un
formidable accélérateur
d'une part comme l'a dit laurent
legendre sur vraiment la capacité à
rencontrer des gens et des gens et ce
qui est très important dans les contacts
qu'on peut obtenir à tech'innove c'est
la pertinence du contact le fait de
avoir un contact à thales c'est bien
mais avoir le contact dans l'innovation
du domaine qui nous intéresse c'est
beaucoup mieux
donc pour nous vraiment tech'innove a
été cet accélérateur d'un réseau
pertinent et d'un réseau qui fonctionne
à plein aujourd'hui notamment
on a rencontré matra électronique et
aujourd'hui on est sur un projet de
collaboration avec matra sur le tout une
partie de développement d'une d'une
centrale d'automatisation de notre
système
donc vraiment cette cet immense chance
d'avoir une une opération de ce type là
c'est la proximité qu'on peut avoir avec
des décideurs qui sont le bon contact
dans la bonne entreprise donc vous à
vous a permis dans un premier temps de
trouver des clients
oui c'était ensuite innocentée en suisse
berne on en a eu la chance d'avoir un
accélérateur suisse qui s'est intéressé
à notre projet et comme la suisse est un
pays qui est très volontariste dans sa
politique vis-à-vis du drone j'espère
être le premier pays à utiliser des
drones taxi et pour nous dans le domaine
du sport quel siège de l'uefa d'une part
et celle du cio d'autre part on a
réalisé pour rugby europe la première
diffusion d'un match en direct capter
avec une captation via drones ces fours
guillaume ouais c'était un très très bon
moment donc ça c'était le premier
premier pas et puis ensuite trouver des
opportunités nouvelles de marché enfin
vrai de voilà exactement de de pouvoir
avoir des contacts les mobiliser au bon
moment c'est à dire au moment où notre
solution progress où nos solutions se
développer vraiment au départ nous on
était parti sur la dimension sportive on
est sept associés qui sont des grosses
missions d'événements sportifs
exactement unis par la passion du rugby
on avait comme idée de faire de la
captation sportives et culturelles comme
une priorité
et puis très vite on s'est rendu compte
que le marché de cette captation il
pouvait être beaucoup plus large et
pouvait être notamment dans le domaine
de tout ce qui était la sécurité des
publics et des territoires vont les
grandes places publiques voisins ouais
c'est aussi tout ce qui est les sites à
risques la particularité de notre
innovation c'est le fait d'être l'objet
volant qui ne tombe jamais et donc de
pouvoir survoler des zones où un drone
classique ne peut pas un n'a pas
l'autorisation réglementaire de de
survoler donc pour nous ça a été
vraiment une ouverture est la plus belle
c'est on va dire que à l'image du petit
prince on voulait viser la lune pour
tomber dans les étoiles
et aujourd'hui on a obtenu un rail
européen pour être le drone qui va
tenter d'analyser le sol martien et
trouver le bon emplacement pour
développer une base humaine le rôle aux
côtés d'elie véniel c'est une fierté je
pense que c'est une fierté j'ai
rencontré olivier tech innove et je vais
inviter chez airbus puisque quand on
voit les capacités d'innovation de son
drone sa spécificité qui est de pouvoir
s'affranchir des règles de la dg à les
démultiplication dans le domaine de la
sécurité elle est énorme
on peut penser aux jeux olympiques qu'on
peut penser à des événements comme ça
que l'on peut on va pouvoir sécuriser
avec cette technologie
c'est probable
c'est la société s'appelle donc hyperion
c'est votre droit
on essaie d'associer hyperion c'est le
dieu grec qui voit tout ce qu'ils voient
tous et l'humour est à l'origine des des
chercheurs à l'origine on est deux dans
l'équipe à être des chercheurs issus des
deux laboratoires j'ai cité et pour les
autres on est allé chercher les
compétences transverses dont on avait
besoin pour réussir ce projet et
reparler par exemple puisque c'est à ce
tout le monde est concerné passe à des
retransmissions sportives où on peut on
peut espérer voir des retransmissions
sportives réalisées par hyperion seven
on espère très fortement pour la
deuxième partie de l'année 2021 donc à
partir de septembre et on a fait
beaucoup de décès avec avec m6 notamment
sur le foot féminin avec canal+ beaucoup
sur le rugby y est élaboré sur le foot
et puis on est allés filmer le la coupe
du monde de ski à chamonix pour faire
des images qui étaient absolument
sublime et il ya toute une partie qui
nous intéresse aussi sur les hippodromes
groupement technique des hippodromes
parisiens et le pmu ou là il ya vraiment
des opportunités très très très
intéressante
et puis on a on a une collaboration
aussi où l'an dernier on était en finale
de ce fameux challenge de tech'innove et
avec airbus il ya aussi beaucoup de
projets potentiels à réaliser dans ce
domaine autant sur le spatial que sur la
partie notamment aujourd'hui on
travaille beaucoup avec la marine
nationale
bravo bravo parce que c'est vrai que
c'est formidable
quelques se fait rêver 2019
c'est formidable on pourra aller sur
mars avec un drone c'est incroyable
la famille le temps qu'il faut pour y
aller autant que ce soit un drone
merci merci beaucoup mais je crois qu'on
va voir passer à la cérémonie de remise
des prix si vous avez comme en hollande
bien sûr on va on va donner la parole
aux quatre pôles de compétitivité qui
ont animé ces challengers d'accord
commencer par le prix paul vaut mieux
prick et le prix est due selon ge
aerotec et c'est marie christine oghly
et qui est président du pôle de
compétitivité de aztèques qui va nous en
parler bonjour bonjour je voudrais tout
d'abord remercier laurent legendre pour
pour son action il fait partie bien
entendu de notre pôle il est très actif
et quand il m'a sollicité j'ai tout de
suite dit oui même si le pôle est
impliqué déjà depuis des années sur
tech'innove alors que le pôle le pôle
aztèque c'est le pôle aéronautique
espace et défense en ile de france mais
c'est un pôle qui est sur un marché qui
tend à se développer aussi vers le
nouveau segment émergent tels que
l'urban air mobility on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment et on va pas en
parler encore plus et peut-être au
moment des jeux olympiques didier on a
parlé tout à l'heure en tout cas des
jeux olympiques
nous couvrons toutes les compétences
métiers danseuses un pôle qui est un
pôle marchés
donc tout ce qui va être les procédés de
fabrication les matériaux les essais les
architectures les systèmes embarqués
c'est vraiment pour cette raison que
nous soutenons tech'innove parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'innovations dans nos
entreprises membres
et depuis la première heure nous
participons on va la première heure
d'astek nous participons à tech'innove 1
dès 2008 nous étions déjà présents
nous avons participé donc à tech'innove
faire partie du jury du challenge
aerotec c'était donc tout à fait naturel
pour pour nous pour aztèque
mais c'est également à l'honneur car
cela nous permet de croiser des gens qui
sont passionnés qui sont porteurs
d'innovation et et parfois de véritables
ruptures technologiques et c'est
vraiment cette cette dynamique c
enthousiasme que nous aimons accueillis
au sein du pôle aztèque alors au dehors
de avant d'abandonner le le gagne au jeu
il faut rappeler le prix aerotec c'est
vrai vous l'avez dit mais c'est de
répondre aux enjeux de l'aéronautique de
demain c'est ça oui absolument
alors vous voulez donner le gagner ou si
vous voulez donner il faut que je passe
à d'abord un petit jingle pour le voyez
que la cérémonie est quand même un peu
de retenue donc on va passer de tête de
jingle le prix du challenge
aerotech
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors avant avant que vous donniez
d'ailleurs le nom du gagnant
c'est notre vie peut-être est-ce que
c'est et c'était une compétition serrée
oui on a d'ailleurs beaucoup échanger
entre nous changer on est revenue sur
des décisions on a on a eu beaucoup de
difficulté à départir vraiment à
départager les gagnants
donc je pense qu'ils sont effectivement
extrêmement méritants et je voudrais
dire que au delà de la remise d'un
simple prix pour nous nous sommes aussi
heureux d'offrir aux lauréats
l'adhésion bien sûr au pôle aztèque est
comme ça nous aurons le plaisir de les
accompagner dans leur développement et
avec le soutien de nos partenaires
et je tiens à partir assez particulier
non didier kling président de la cci
régionale parce que lire cette équipe
font un travail remarquable et participe
régulièrement à nous à nos réunions du
pôle aztèque
donc j'espère qu'à l'avenir nous
pourrons continuer à accompagner cette
société et lui permettre de se
développer ou grandir et peut-être de la
retrouver au csa las vegas c'est un très
beau projet très bien alors il est temps
de passer à la remise du prix oui alors
le prix est remis à timothée gerlinger
de la société opus aerospace
bah bravo bravo et je crois que timothée
jeune linda et est avec nous bonjour
bonjour bonjour ça y est et ben voilà
vous êtes vous êtes heureux je suppose
des et aussi on s'y attendait pas
forcément c'est une société qui est à
vincennes je crois alors notre siège
social est à vincennes mais en fait nous
ateliers sont
en essonne un sol et châteaux donc juste
à côté de saclay surface au plateau de
saclay un pôle de l'innovation et
apprennent ce qui fait très plaisir dit
il est nu alors racontez nous un peu au
pc et rospez c'est vous êtes vous est
spécialisée dans le lancement de mini
satellite ça exactement en fait notre
entreprise conçoit des lanceurs de
satellites
enfin plutôt même de nano satellites
autorités c'est d'envoyer enfin c'est de
fournir aux clients la possibilité
d'envoyer leurs satellites en orbite
basse à dire proche de la terre tant que
leur satellite font moins de 50 kg
donc pour ça on développe un lanceur qu
on opérera l'unm ont fait toute la
chaîne de la fabrication jusqu'à
l'opération entièrement réutilisable
dans le but de créer des économies mais
aussi de réduire notre impact écologique
sur l'environnement et ce qui est
formidable a fallu utiliser un petit peu
autre qui était votre société c'est vrai
que au fond de la conquête spatiale qui
a été des choses énormes et qui coûté
extrêmement cher est aujourd'hui en
train de les dire de se démocratiser
peut-être pas le mot mais enfin d'être à
la portée de tous presque oui
effectivement
justement comme vous le dites le spatial
se démocratise énormément aidé bien
avant le lancement spatial en tout cas
restent non pas avoir tellement mais de
plus en plus à la portée de plusieurs
d'un plus grand nombre au niveau des
entreprises mais aussi par exemple au
niveau des étudiants qui aujourd'hui
peuvent concevoir laure conan aux
satellites lancés avec des sociétés
comme la nôtre par exemple donc je vois
le sac et une grosse démocratisation pas
forcément du lancement que de l'accès à
l'espace pour le plus grand nombre et
ses micro satellite et je suppose qu'il
ya plusieurs plusieurs utilisations
possibles vers quoi vers quoi quels sont
les centres de recherche les plus les
plus gros alors en fait la plante des
nano satellites vont être différentes de
différent
acteur on va voir les communications
dans des appels des constellations c'est
à dire des maillages de satellites
autour de la terre pour apporter tout ce
qui est telle et comme mais ailleurs
aussi dans le monde deux satellites
d'observation de la terre c'est là
qu'ils vont être très proche de la terre
est voué le la planète que ce soit
niveau bas de l'agriculture des océans
mais aussi pour la photographie aussi un
peu le point militaires m'ont évidemment
à l'observation un militaire des des
sites l'espionnage donc je vois là il ya
différentes applications mais aussi
l'application du tournant scientifique
et pure recherche sociale souvent menées
par des étudiants c'est à dire des
universités qui vont lancer des
satellites un but de recherche
scientifique que ce soit dans vos
recherches menées par la sortie des
satellites serre sur la technologie de
super league ou bien par des prises de
mesures effectuées dans l'espace pour
faire avancer la science il ya eu
récemment n'est pas le centre spatial de
2,50 à lens 1-1 de satellites
et c'est vrai qu'il disait c'est très
bien d'ailleurs votre votre votre
entreprise il examen du mal justement à
trouver des lanceurs essence d'été
obligé de passer par des américains
c'est formidable parce que vous faites
du coup mais le problème c'est que le
marché américain est très prenant sur le
marché européen ce qui fait que souvent
les acteurs européens se retrouvent à
lancer chasser les chaussées les
américains choix soit chez les indiens
donc reprise du marché et fait par
d'autres pays et fait part d'une
certaine indépendance
oui je me souviens de cet honneur saint
quentin qui va tirer celle spécifique et
voilà on aimerait bien bhl dans le futur
pouvoir récupérer ces universités de
l'argent versé par l'état reste en
france ben je crois qu'il serait ravi de
travailler avec vous un mot sur
notre idée dès lors la gendarmerie chez
airbus on fabrique pas mal de satellites
et bien sûr on s'intéresse au new space
est forcément avoir un candidat qui
vient de ce monde du new space pour nous
c'est formidable on n'est pas du tout
concurrent mais plutôt complémentaires
parce que là on parle du projet se passe
à 400 km d'altitude oui c'est ça après
c'est un nouveau domaine
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de new space
très bien et bien bravo bravo dit oui et
dédaigneux ce que vient dire laurent est
quand même symptomatique de de la
politique des groupes qui se rapproche
de start up comme celle ci de manière à
faire une synergie moi je trouve que
c'est fantastique pur plus si c'est avec
quelqu'un du plateau de saclay ce temps
quand même
et comme les communes comme dit l'autre
jour on n'est pas tous grands on est
complet mais voilà c'est ça le secret ou
folie et un petit accent mot bravo
timothée der linde heures bravo aux
puces aerospace eurospa suspects sont
des icônes en haut puis sert au space
c'est notre nom commercial mais on
envisage peut-être de soins des hôpitaux
spécial parce qu'on est français et donc
c'était le prix du cerveau aux aerotec
bravo on va passer au 2e prix c'est le
prix du challonge mobilité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour nous présenter ce prix du
challenge mobilité qui récompense des
solutions de déplacement innovantes au
service de tous c'est philippe orvain
qui est vice président du pôle de
compétitivité next move pour
l'ile-de-france qui est avec nous
bonjour bonjour bonjour à toute femme
donc effectivement je vais présenter
rapidement en équipement vins qui en
fait la fusion de mauvais au le pôle
d'innovation des mobilités et des arias
en particulier en ile-de-france le
rallye qui s'occupait de performance
industrielle
donc aujourd'hui on a des 2 et de
chapeaux qui sont réunis dans un même
pôle de compétitivité dont on a changé
le nom et qui s'occupe donc une part
d'innovation dans le domaine du véhicule
connecté autonome les nouveaux services
de mobilité et d'autre part de
l'industrie 4.0 en particulier sur les
industries automobile et des sous
traitants dont ceux de la particularité
de ce secteur un pôle qui a deux
antennes régionales qui représente
l'acsel delà de la mobilité on appelle
ça la mobility vallée voilà pour faire
un plagiat avec la californie donc c'est
un rôle comme tous les pôles qui
regroupent des pme qui regroupe des
grands groupes qui regroupe des labos
qui regroupe aussi des collectivités
territoriales ou une expo a vocation à
être donc une aide pour l'aménagement et
le dernier assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvragé sur les projets de mobilité
pour s'essayer pour ces collectivités
territoriales donc vous deviez là je
tiens à remercier et quine à 20 c'est
franchement une une manifestation qui
quitte un grand intérêt et remercier
aussi aurélie reprend les qualités des
des candidatures puisque on a recueilli
une
douzaine de candidatures qui est
excellent on en a choisi six pour les
finales donc dans l'es6 je peux être
excité parce que sa lente et difficile
icd et des sociétés comme on vraiment un
intérêt il ya société cap qui propose de
faire des drones pour transporter des
personnes
donc c'est un choix très intéressant qui
dit mode qui fait des dt services pour
accompagner des personnes malvoyantes
dans les pros sport mk d'or pour la cedh
1 à 10 images pour la sécurité en
particulier et il voie ferrée neptec qui
fait des du transport naval intelligente
et assez révolutionnaire c'est déjà fini
qui fait du rétrofit de vie du permis
pour véhicules électriques
et puis une boîte que j'aime beaucoup
qui s'appelle you vocaux qui est
porteuse de sujets sur des solutions de
vito x1 commissaire du véhicule avec par
sa structure et notre véhicule et qui
développe des produits depuis quelques
années qui a pour intérêt ça s'est fini
c'est les gens qui sont qui ont été
sélectionnés par le jury qui était
constituée donc de de plusieurs
personnes de cité qui s'appelle
alexandra mazars bco la tribe arthur
puis leur lit métriques de riz agnès
breton du magazine environnement
magazine typo fut she does total
je lis mes notes sébastien magne matin
en partant de 10 semaines en même temps
parler on les voit aussitôt que vous en
parlez donc c'est tout va tout va bien
vous inquiétez pas donc puis du bateau
arctic tu fait de tes com et puis moi
même donc fêté discussions 13 ans à
prouver et donc à vous voulez déjà le
gagnant lorsque c'était 2 lorsque des
délibérations de temps
à enquêter tant pis goethe de neptec
avec une équipe d'ingénieurs assez
formidable sont en train de concevoir un
véhicule qui a très peu de tirant d'eau
qui porte qui peut supporter 20 tonnes
et qui navigue alors que c'est ça
l'intérêt alors c'est un petit peu
décalé par rapport à contrer chesnais
cmo on a plutôt l'habitude des
transports terrestres mais c'est
extrêmement intéressant puisque la le
fleuve le fleuve est quand même un outil
historique de croissance économique un
pur pour le transport des marchandises
et donc c'est un transport adapté à la
fois pour le fret et pour les bons mais
il valait mieux puisqu'il va revenir je
suppose et dûment absolument merci
beaucoup militent pour le oui nous
sommes avec toby gad qui essaient ou et
confondateur de neptec donc oui je finis
pour valider en réalité vous faites des
catamarans à propulsion électrique c'est
ça oui tout à fait bonjour à tous tout
d'abord donc on conçoit des navires des
navires de transport transport de
passagers de marchandises et ce sont des
catamarans à propulsion en ligne
électrique donc alimenté soit par des
systèmes 100% batterie soit par des
piles à combustible hydrogène en réalité
un système hybride ix à combustible
hydrogène et des batteries ce sont des
navires qui sont au zéro émission qui
sont performants vraiment le coeur de
l'innovation données est de travailler
sur la réduction de la consommation
énergétique pour avoir le navire zéro
émission le plus performant possible et
intelligent avec l'intégration de
systèmes d'assistance au pilotage est le
cofondateur de netex kogo est née cette
idée de 2 c au fonds de se transporter
disons c'est c'est tout d'abord l'équipe
on est on est à trois associés on
clément rousset qui est notre ingénieur
naval à corentin ricot qui est notre
architecte naval et puis moi qui ai
intervient plus sur le volet business
finance avec avec des expériences dans
l'industrie aéronautique et dans
l'industrie navale
on a décidé de mettre en commun ou
compétences qui étaient
multidisciplinaire et qui étaient
complémentaires pour ce type de projet
est de mettre du coup nos compétences au
service de l'aide au développement d'une
solution qui réponde est un problème
majeur qui est la congestion et la
pollution dans les centres urbains
la plupart des grandes villes sont
situées au bord d'une voie d'eau et ses
voies d'eau sont sous utilisés faute de
moyens de mobilité navale adaptée aux
enjeux environnementaux adaptée aux
enjeux en termes de performances et de
vitesse de ce type de mobilité qu'on va
réhabiliter plus traditionnels comme
comme le bus ou le train et donc on se
retrouve avec ses oiseaux qui sont des
sortes de d'autoroute complètement
déserte en plein centre ville
c'est du transport et de marchandises et
de et de passage annoncé ça va tourner
tout à fait en fait on sait qu'on s'est
inspiré de l'industrie automobile c'est
à dire qu'on a développé un châssis
commun une plate-forme commune dans le
cas de la vire ce sont des coques et de
le système de propulsion qui est commun
et ensuite on va personnaliser tout ce
qui est en dehors de vos c'est à dire
qu'on va pouvoir avoir une cabine de
transport de passagers on applications
maritimes c'est le négociateur
on a une application coût du transport
de passagers fluvial a pris peur et
ensuite une version le net
carbo pour le transport de marchandises
qui permet en fait de faire des
livraisons aux l'avant dernier kilomètre
donc donc l'objectif de de ce type de
liaison c'est de pouvoir assurer le lien
entre le centre logistique téléphérique
et le centre-ville lors d'un pour
livraison comme vous voyez ici à l'écran
du dernier kilomètre
en mode doute il fait le cas on est
impressionné quand même parler
d'innovation à chaque fois formidable
non
on parle beaucoup d'hydrogène pour
l'avion de 2035 chérioux mais là si on
voit que sur les voies fluviales
on aura d'hydrogène probablement avant
et grâce à une start up
oui c'est vrai c'est impressionnant quoi
alarmer moi je l'innovation
l'intelligence en vain surtout que
surtout des villes des villes comme
paris qui ont leur port sur le havre
donc l'important c'est donc c'est devant
de la scène qu'il faut utiliser qui est
sous sous j'utilise et il avait raison
goethe on n'utilise pas ces lots enfin
les transports
par contre et là vous vos projets vous
êtes vous êtes déjà implantés dans des
villes alors alors oui principalement
sur la façade méditerranéenne et sur la
façade des politiques 12 et aix en
provence mais on est basé en province
sur l'aisne sur la métropole aix
marseille
incubé la pépinière cleantech et on est
effectivement en train de travailler sur
différents projets de d'exploitation de
nos navires quand on parle effectivement
de navires hydrogène faut penser à tout
l'écosystème c'est pas c'est pas
seulement le délit c'est également
l'espèce une recharge depuis
l'approvisionnement de ses stations de
recharge hydrogène d'air l'objectif
étant évidemment de limiter nos navires
avec de l'hydrogène terre c'est pas
forcément de sens de se tourner vers ce
type de mode de propulsion
donc on est on est en discussion et
d'une quinzaine d'exploitants ben
écoutez bravo bravo et on espère aussi
le cycle le ce prix de tech'innove a
évidemment vous aider je pense que ça
aide forcément non si vous passez sous
contrôle ça devient quelque chose de sa
mort
c'est un must samus maintenant d'être
primé par équipes merci merci et bravo
tony goetz et je rappelle donc neptec
c'est le nom de cette société qui fait
des catamarans à propulsion électrique
et on va passer au troisième prix ces
deux prix du challenge elle steak
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va passer dans un domaine phare
de l'innovation qui est celui de la
santé et pour parler de ce prix du
challenge le speck jacques lg si ns et
ses collègues
bonjour vous êtes délégué général du
pôle compétitivité de médis m
je vous laisse je vous laisse la parole
alors pour ce prix quelques mots a donc
medicen c'est le pôle santé de l'île de
france on est actif trois filières de la
nec à savoir les bibliothèques les
medtechs et la licence et est
aujourd'hui mais 10ème c'est à raison de
presque 500 ans dans plus de 400
start-up tpe et pme innovantes dont une
quarantaine d'acteurs académique parmi
les cadeaux les organismes de recherche
en santé principaux l'échelle nationale
et puis les établissements en
ile-de-france dont l'ap-hp et d'autres
et d'autres centres hospitaliers nouveau
les universités et des grandes écoles et
des grands groupes et b et d ati du
secteur et comme dans un mois la pomme
accompagnent au quotidien les
entreprises retour de l'action passe
mais bien sûr on est ni d'écosystèmes
pour l'accès aux financements publics et
privés et pour les démarches de
développement à l'europe et à
l'international où je suis ravie
aujourd'hui de présenter effectivement à
le les lauréats gagnant du challenge
respecte on a eu la chance de participer
au jury aux côtés j'ai locaux
l'entreprise avec monique et thomas de
laurence lacroix aurions de janot pôle
ados de charisme d'isabelle de crème ou
de séries nature partners allen le floch
et d'eric rebiffer de sanofi et donc
pour les 10 mg un bond au classement ça
plus la chine air vont mettre taquet
lachance évaluer les candidatures alors
cette belle candidature
c'est vrai que ce domaine de la santé du
médicament aussi c'est un domaine
extraordinaire de l'innovation c'est un
des domaines où les innovations et la
plus la plupart côte
tout à fait c'est il se passe des choses
et on peut voir en ce moment des
révolutions évidemment en pleine crise
sanitaire qui couvre aujourd'hui
l'innovation en santé est un enjeu
majeur et on voit de nombreuses
révolutions en ce moment notamment en ce
qui concerne les données de santé c'est
une des choses qui bouleverse des cycles
de développement des nouveaux produits
et services de la santé il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de belles entreprises qui ont
des chansons alors vous disiez mais oui
bon évidemment plusieurs finalistes pour
ce prix voilà alors pour vous en dire un
petit peu plus il ya eu la société admis
qui développe un logiciel de gestion et
d'analysé des données multi book la
société lui madix qui développe un test
de diag utilisé des nanoparticules
luminescentes ultra sensibilité pour le
diagnostic
la société fabrique qui développe une
technologie de circularisation adn pour
les laboratoires et les producteurs de
vieux véhicules
la société civile à yves qui développe
une technologie qui permet de lutter
contre la mort cellulaire la société
moderne technology qui développent eux
ils soient soumis mon solution de suivi
des risques biomécanique à l'origine des
troubles musculo-squelettiques la
société allemagne qui travaille sur une
solution de reprogrammation de rebond
motrices la migration de la rééducation
des patients très important et la
société william holland qui développe
une petite suivi de lost heroes
intégration d un peu tout ça c'est des
recherches absolument accents du dérivé
d'amour donc ça doit être difficile de
faire de voir deux de trouver un gars
bio par bus par bus cela pas facile en
effet
les aires thérapeutiques les besoins
cliniques qui sont couverts par toutes
ces approches sont évidemment très
important mais voilà après délibération
on a pu choisir le coup de coeur du jury
parce que vous voulez un petit un petit
remontant bourg le gagnant du challenge
stakes et morgen rosnoën la présidente
de ciblage aussi mais live c'est une
entreprise qui développe comme le disait
tout à l'heure des médicaments qui
aident à bloquer la mort simulée réglé
donc ses membres de l'indication de
pathologies différentes des pathologies
aiguës et chroniques et donc un
potentiel pour aider les patients très
très important mais je vais peut-être
laissez-moi également dire
malheureusement non parce que morgan a
est-ce que c'est mort est-ce que c'est
morgane rochelais qui est là on vous
voyez pas on s'y attendait plus mais
morgane vous nous entendez ou pas je
crois qu'on a un petit problème de
liaison avec eux avec morgane rousselet
malheureusement pourtant elle est pas si
loin que ça elle est à roscoff c'est pas
[Musique]
de virus n'y a pas de virus
alors est ce que je sais c'est qu'à vous
pouvez peut-être parce que on a un petit
peu de balles à entendre
morgane rousselet qu'est ce qui vous a
key ce qui vous a motivé justement sur
ce prix sur ces 10 juillet c'était des
médicaments qui sont prêts qu'ils sont
décidés à bloquer ce qu'on appelle la
nécrose réguler c'est à dire la mort des
cellules
tout à fait d'accord le potentiel sur
des indications très différente
envisager des applications
thérapeutiques en néphrologie en
cardiologie sur les maladies oculaires
neurodégénératives c'est d'abord le
potentiel pour les patients qui est très
vaste et puis une stratégie aussi de
développement qui était bien pensé qui a
séquencé avec une priorité au ciblage de
pathologies aiguës avec un traitement
unique et cours pouvoir faciliter le
plan clinique et ensuite s'il voulait
plutôt des pathologies chroniques qui
sont plus répandus et pour lequel si peu
développement pour être cloud morgan est
ce que nous aurons organes à formidable
salué la liaison est établi avec avec
roscoff
cécile brossard aux cov alors oui alors
jessica linga très très bien expliqué
votre votre découverte là se défaire de
siby life mais peut-être pouvais te dire
un mot justement sur cette de recherche
sur cette entreprise biotechnologique
kessy belief oui alors merci beaucoup
déjà sélectionné le projet donc gravi et
toute l'équipe est ravie d'avoir été
sélectionnés et retenus dont on
développe des petites molécules qui
déprogramment la mort cellulaire selon
un mécanisme d'action original et
breveté et on développe ces molécules
pour traiter différents types de
pathologies sévères sans alternative
thérapeutique efficace
donc on s'adresse en particulier aux
attaques brutales et massives du foie et
du rhin dans l'insuffisance rénale
hépatique aiguë mais on s'adresse aussi
à disques emi cardiaque non pathologies
oculaires comme la deuxième est là et
aux maladies neurodégénératives parce
que dans ces malades ils ont toutes en
commun et l'activation synergique de
deux mort cellulaire réguliers que nous
avons bloqué avec grâce à nos molécules
et à nous sommes les seuls à développer
cette approche conditions dieu c'est le
beau jeu c'est assez facile et enfin
quand vous parlez de ça parce que c'est
vrai que c'est jusqu'à présent des
balades et d'autres se disait qu'on
pouvait peut-être pas les soigner et
grâce à des recherches des recherches
comme les vôtres ça ouvre des espoirs
formidable c'est une entreprise qui est
qui date de quand sybiline alors
l'entreprise a été créée en mars 2019
mais c'est un projet un projet une
collaboration déjà entre trois
laboratoires académiques démarre en 2013
lors de cette collaboration qui relie un
ingénieur de recherche du cnrs à la
station biologique de roscoff une
directrice de recherche de l'inserm à
rennes et deux chimistes de l'université
claude bernard à lyon
donc allons en 2013 ils se retrouvent
autour d'un projet collaboratif financée
par l'institut national du cancer
et c'est là qu'il met en évidence ces
molécules d'intérêt thérapeutique en
criblant en allant chercher des
molécules dans des chimiothèques des
bibliothèques
deux molécules originales qui ont été
reconstitués à roscoff mais aussi à lyon
et met en évidence et ces molécules
d'intérêt et dépose trois familles de
brevets en 2015 et en 2016 et en ceux
qui sont financés par les dispositifs de
la stat ouest valorisation et avec
l'idée de valoriser ses travaux de
recherche en créant une start up et moi
j'interviens sur le projet en 2018 alors
je suis scientifique de formation mais
j'ai une expérience entrepreneuriale
j'ai participé déjà à des reprises à la
création et au développement de start up
en biotechnologie et donc de cette
rencontre est de cette complémentarité
d'expériences et en crée la société en
mars 2010neuf nous pour valoriser ces
molécules et développer le plus loin
possible en développement clinique
écoutez on vous félicite
ophélie site bravo bravo bravo continuez
vous regarde rosselet sibilla est requis
et donc le prix du sol aux hells tech
deck enough 2021 merci infiniment
on va pas rater on va passer au dernier
prix qui est un prix important pour ça
il faut garder aussi un peu de temps
parce que malheureusement on a pris un
peu de retard
c'est le prix du challenge numérique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour parler de ce prix et de deux
choix du jury
on accueille karine jack bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le délégué général du pôle de
compétitivité systematic paris région
absolument je vous remercie pour cette
invitation cette belle opportunité
systématique et partenaires de
tech'innove de la première heure parce
que je crois qu'on est en partenariat
avec la chambre de commerce depuis la
création du pôle en 2005 sur le plateau
de saclay systématique aujourd'hui
c'était une équipe de 40 personnes et
qui anime un écosystème de 900 membres
adhérents dont 6 100 startups pme tei
150 grands groupes 150 académique avec
un ancrage fort évidemment sur le
plateau de saclay sur l'ensemble de
l'île de france on anime aussi un
collège d'investisseurs un collège de
collectivités territoriales avec
lesquels on interagit beaucoup sur des
sujets autour de la transformation
numérique qui est un sujet évidemment
éminemment d'actualité systématique et
organisé autour de six hubs très
technologiques autour des datas sciences
de l'ia de la cyber de la sécurité de la
guillotine mais aussi l'optique la
photonique et l'open source
le digital ijen herring et on adresse
trois grands enjeux qui sont la
transformation numérique des territoires
la transformation numérique de
l'industrie et des services et la
transformation numérique de la société
au travers notamment de la santé sur
lesquels on travaille beaucoup avec
mehdi scène au travers notamment des
sujets de e-santé mais aussi de l'agrile
agrotech qui sont de plus en plus
demandeurs de solutions numériques alors
au niveau de six thématiques
on a effectivement eu l'opportunité
d'animer ce challenge avec un jury donc
qui je n'étais pas tout seul évidemment
avec aline
car un nicolas du cea list françoise
soulié qui dirige la france il ya
benjamin zerbib de cariste à et puis
hervé naudin du groupe orange et donc on
a eu pas mal de très beaux dossiers à a
expertisé notamment les sept entreprises
qui ont été retenus par par le jury
étaient les suivantes agiléo qui propose
des solutions informatique et robotique
pour les équipements de production pour
l'industrie agora qui est une plateforme
de collaboration en langage naturel pour
les yachts y donc l'internet des objets
nuage qui est une plateforme de
prédiction automatisé hertault ce qui
est une qui propose une solution
logicielle pour accélérer et sécuriser
les développements d'applications
embarquées ayo qui fly for you qui est
une société qui propose des solutions
d'identification des phases de vie
d'équipements industriels oximax avec
ses solutions de sauvegarde des données
et puis keep somme qui est un
gestionnaire énergétiques intelligents
et connectés
alors j'aurai droit le monde tambours
oui elle était alors le gagnant du
challenge numérique et j'en suis
doublement ravi est aussi membre de
systématique et c'est un heureux hasard
il s'agit de la société oxymore qui
représenté par françois feugeas et qui
permet de garantir la pérennité des
données de toutes les entreprises mais
j'espère qu'il est à connecter à bout il
y va il est avec nous
il est avec de bons jours françoise
dolto chasse vous êtes directeur de 2,6
box qui est d'ailleurs à guyancourt pas
très loin d'ici
c'est une société qui est garanti la
pérennité des deux des entreprises
la résistance aux cyberattaques et la
restauration évidemment des données la
protection de ses données
c'est bien ça tout à fait et merci
à tous merci merci au jury on est très
fiers de remporter ce challenge donc
effectivement notre métier c'est la
cyber résilience donc la capacité en
fait à pouvoir garantir le redémarrage
rapide des systèmes d'information après
une cyberattaque est évidemment en ce
moment c'est parfaitement d'actualité
après un round 5 mois et l'entreprise de
vous laver créé con alors l'entreprise
est relativement âgés l'entreprise a été
créée en 2014 et en fait on a
autofinancé alors dont on vieillit on
trouvait de le rejoindre et et d'idées
dès 2014 servent encore c'est pas les
jeunes
vpour pour une start up on est déjà
effectivement une vieille start up entre
guillaume et puisqu'on a autopsiant
autofinancé nos technologies innovantes
pendant cinq ans donc on a fait cinq ans
de recherche et développement en fonds
propres pour pour sortir le produit
la cyberattaque on a parfois
l'impression que les grandes entreprises
qui en sont les victimes c'est vrai tout
le monde en est victime aujourd'hui
alors absolument à faire qu'on entend
par les empreintes de compte que des
grandes entreprises et on n'entend
parler que des collectivités
territoriales ou des établissements
hospitaliers puisque eux sont en fin de
compte
obligé contraint à communiquer mais donc
une forme en fin de compte que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg
et comme un vrai iceberg le gros de
l'iceberg
ça va être des tpe pme qui n'ont pas
forcément envie de communiquer et qui
n'ont pas forcément par ailleurs un
intérêt économique communiqué et
aujourd'hui on estime à grosso modo que
il y a à peu près une attaque par minute
en france par ransomware donc il ya
énormément de victimes
énormément c'est une attaque mais
n'étaient par minute c'est absolument
incroyable et on a aujourd'hui les
moyens de se prémunir du protégé de
répondre à ces attaques
on a difficilement les moyens de les
empêcher complètement il ya des mesures
de protection effectivement que les
entreprises peuvent prendre pour ikeda
des cibles faciles et pour empêcher
qu'ils attaquent à deviennent rapidement
mais en fin de compte la question c'est
pas tant si on va être attaqué la
question c'est plutôt quand est ce qu'on
va être attaqué on peut retarder
l'échéance et d'une certaine manière il
est inéluctable qu'au bout d'un moment
on en soit victime notre métier chez oak
cibox est justement de faire en sorte qu
après l attaque on soit en mesure de
redémarrer très bien donc eh bah bravo
vous avez un beau a ajouté claude gendre
auxi box est une entreprise que l'on
connaît bien chez airbus airbus airbus
et est peu connu pour travailler dans la
cybersécurité mais c'est aussi à nos
domaines nous avons des collaborations
avec loppsi box qui protège des des
clients qui sont pas forcément ceux
d'airbus qui sont plutôt les pme qui ont
besoin d'entreprises comme auxi boxe
parce que c'est là où il ya le gros
problème est donc donc là encore pas de
concurrence on peut agir ensemble
vous disiez tout à l'heure merci merci
beaucoup et bravo à nankin auxi bugs et
longue vie à auxi boxe enfin j'espère
même si on espère toujours ne pas avoir
besoin d'hommes enfin on en aura besoin
[Rires]
on a on a eu donc les quatre lauréats de
2 c selon ge
on va peut-être passer maintenant la
parole alexandre bout oui bonjour
bonjour vous êtes avocat au sein du
département droit fiscal de finale et
vous avez aussi vous même
prix à remettre oui alors tout à fait
nous on est donc un cabinet d'avocats
d'affaires on est un cabinet assez
important puisqu'on est plus de 1000
avocats en france sur 90 implantations
et on a une forte implantation en région
parisienne et notamment dans les
yvelines à versailles où effectivement
on accompagne donc dans tous les
domaines du droit des affaires les
dirigeants et les entreprises s'assurent
un champ de compétence assez large
puisque ça va du droit fiscal au droit
social en passant par effectivement
l'ensemble des problématiques juridiques
peuvent rencontrer des entreprises et on
a effectivement développé une forme
practice pour l'accompagnement des
entreprises innovantes et donc on peut
on répond à leurs questions en matière
de propriété intellectuelle de brevets
et cela à toutes les différentes phases
de la révolution donc sa patte leur
constitution jusqu'à effectivement à des
levées de fonds et et autres à ce titre
là d'ailleurs on a participé aujourd'hui
à quelques webinaire sur des points
techniques qui pouvaient intéresser les
entreprises innovantes
on est partenaire historique du du
tech'innove maintenant depuis plus de
six ans on est un partenaire important
puisque justement croit en ses projets
d'innovation et on est heureux donc de
remettre à chacun des lauréats un
rendez-vous de coaching pour
effectivement évoqué avec eux leurs
différents problèmes dans différentes
problématiques juridiques et
effectivement répondre aux questions qui
peuvent se poser
bravo bravo c'était très très belle très
belle initiative
merci beaucoup alexandre beau merci
merci beaucoup
est ce que je crois benoît fethi est
avec nous ce qu'il est avec nous et il
est là un jour je dois effectivement
vous êtes le vice-président de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie des
hauts-de-seine et la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie elle aussi remettre
des prix dans big enough a absolument
avant toute chose je voulais encore
remercier la cci de l'essonne et son
président didier pour l'organisation le
travail remarquable qui permet de mettre
en lumière toutes les entreprises
innovantes du territoire donc c'est
formidable merci beaucoup
nous en fait on intervient sur l'offre
de financement et vous savez qu'il n'y a
pas d'innovation et de développement des
entreprises sans financement et je pense
que c'est la recherche cette recherche
de financement et en particulier pendant
cette crise est un axe majeur un autre
axe majeur pour les dirigeants et donc
c'est ainsi que la c6 des hauts-de-seine
pilote pour le compte de la ccit ile de
france
l'activité de financement des
entreprises en jouant un rôle
d'accélérateur d'accès à ce fameux
financement juste pour illustrer les
rôles de cette business unit financement
est juste quelques chiffres d'abord elle
comprend il faut savoir qu'elle comprend
dix experts disent expert en financement
de l'innovation et de la croissance en
2020 c'est simplement 135 entreprises
ont été accompagnées et qui ont levé
14.5 millions d'euros on voyait c'est
vraiment un des moteurs de la croissance
de ces entreprises
il s'agit d'un accompagnement est
complètement personnalisé un pour
accélérer l'accès à ces différentes
sources de financement
et aujourd'hui même là pendant la
journée tête qui lobe on a eu trois
experts qui ont proposé des rendez vous
à 45 dirigeants et donc on pense que ça
sera efficace comme comme toute
organisation
voilà et nous propose un prix donc qui
est tout simplement l'équipe des
financements qui a repéré notamment des
entreprises audit de france il s'agit de
opus aeros passé et roxy box et l'idée
c'est de leur proposer un diagnostic
financier et de leur permettre un accès
facilité aux financements aussi bien
privé
que public voilà et je pense que ils
pourront ainsi consolider leur plan de
financement
en tous les cas au nom de toute la cci
et de toutes les cci de france voilà où
je transmets tous mes voeux de succès à
l'ensemble de ses norias parce que
c'était extrêmement enthousiasmant
d'écouter tous ces projets très
innovants et de développement très
prometteur pour l'avenir merci merci
beaucoup mais on doit fêter bravo pour
cette initiative parce que c'est en
effet le nerf de la guider la guerre
alors on arrive à la fin de cette
cérémonie de remise des prix
take it off d'idées des nues peut-être
moi j'ai été frappée en effet par
l'intelligence par l'innovation par des
lauréats notamment mais est sans doute
de tous ceux qui ont concouru ses prix
alors moi depuis depuis des années
puisque j'ai j'ai vécu tous tous et tous
étaient qui n'offrent pas le tout
premier puisque je suis arrivé qu'en
2010 mais j'ai les yeux d'enfant j'ai
les yeux qui s'écarquillent gc c'est le
rêve c'est extraordinaire c'est est
magnifique et et j'aimerais bien avoir
20 ans - pour voir tout ce nouveau monde
qui est en train de se créer c'est
l'excellence française à la norme et cc
c'est fantastique à chaque fois chaque
fois que je je je sors de tech'innove je
suis revigoré je trouve que c'est
sensationnel quoi bon je vais je vais
pas être très très long parce que on a
débordé puis beaucoup de choses ont été
dites mais je voudrais avoir une pensée
pour trois personnes
jean claude charvin qui a été le premier
président de tech'innove et qui était à
l'initiative de tech'innove bruno mal
quand qui est notre directeur général
qui est parti à la retraite et qui s'est
beaucoup investi ou sur tech'innove et
je peux pas oublier christophe pillon
qui était le prédécesseur d'henri et qui
a fait un très très très gros travail on
peut le remercier
bien évidemment bien évidemment il faut
faut tirer un grand coup de chapeau
d'une part à aurélie pour pour l'immense
travail qu'elle a fait mais plus pour
pour laurent qui est à la manoeuvre
fantastique merveilleux continuer c'est
bien on continuera vous à vous suivre et
comme on l'a dit l'année prochaine et en
présentiel
et en dix ans ciel parce que il faut que
tech'innove continue il faut peut-être
qu'ils neufs continuent à progresser
dans cette édition elle preuve il y
avait vraiment des nouveautés on l'a
évoqué un les rendez-vous 365
donc c'est que pendant un mois la la
plateforme restent ouvertes pour ces
échanges et puis le challenge open
innovation défense et sécurité d'airbus
et de mba temps dira peut-être un mot
tout à l'heure si tu le souhaites
et puis je voudrais pas non plus
conclure sans remercier nos partenaires
des intercommunalités puisque nous avons
comme cet internaute une
intercommunalité qui nous soutiennent
je vais quand même est nommé grand paris
grand parc en tort lycénes bièvre grand
paris sud est à venir grand paris sud
seine essonne sénart paris-ouest la
défense paris saclay saint quentin en
yvelines et versailles grand parc un
grand grand merci à ces territoires
parce qu'on a besoin d'eux et puis un
grand merci à tout le monde pour la
réussite de cette de cette année
tech'innove 2021 merci beaucoup d'idées
leur légende alors tech'innove dix neuf
et donc technos termine passage rappelé
à ses ils ont tout le mond avril 1 voilà
nous avons encore pour tous les gens qui
ont fait toutes ces demandes de rendez
vous la possibilité de les servir
pendant un mois
ça c'est très important ça continue et
puis on innove aussi parce que cette
année on fait un challenge de plus qui
est un challenge qui va se dérouler
pendant ce mois et où on va pouvoir
n'ont pas sélectionné sur un concours de
pitch mais sélectionné sur des
rendez-vous des entreprises dans le
domaine de la défense avec mbd à airbus
très bien et malgré voilà les
circonstances sanitaires vous êtes
suppose un président heureux oui oui
tout à fait les chiffres que je vous ai
cités tout à leur montre le que l'on ne
s'était pas trompé et que on a bien fait
d'organiser ce cette forme
dématérialisée contre contrôler
les problèmes de la crise sanitaire nous
avons trouvé la solution
merci voilà merci et merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi tu es qui doivent donc
continuer pendant tout le mois d'avril
et puis on attend presque avec
impatience 2022
ce qu'on peut regretter c'est que
d'habitude on comptait toujours par un
bon moment de convivialité conduit là ça
sera voie qu'ont eu lieu les 7 bureaux
d'études
merci merci à tous les deux merci à tous
et à très vite bas pour des nouvelles de
take it off
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]